I love chaos I'm doing 800 things and
start doing it that's right and any time
I know I'm about to do so I did
vaynermedia head down for five years to
build a foundation I don't think all
people this everybody that's gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 304 of
the askgaryvee show and I'm really
excited for this next guest and we're
coming in super cold Nick do my team
said hey I think Strauss should be on
your show I'm like 100 percent being
invited to a Strauss party maybe nine
years ago and then in the tech kind of
media scene was a super highlight for me
and some of you who know me know that
Ben lair is a very good friend of mine
and earlier that like three months
earlier than that party Ben and I suck
you know how like guys or gals get into
like a meme of like something that's
funny to them somehow a movie called
Ghoulies became this like really funny
thing for you know that movie was it
yeah I was a little bit of both here's
the punchline
somehow at Sundance this movie Ghoulies
which I didn't know about but then like
in this weekend it became the most
important thing in my life so then a
couple months later we go to Strauss's
house for this event or what have you
somehow we're not a lot of people are
left and somehow me and Ben are just
somehow it gets referenced Ghoulies like
we say something it's like the inside
joke it's the meme and Strauss goes I
made that movie which to this day is a
top like 10 stress and I have not spent
a whole lot of time together we have a
lot of mutual friends I have an enormous
amount of admiration from him from afar
we'll get I'm gonna let him paint a five
minute context of his career and then
we'll do some Q&A because I think he's
gonna help a lot of entrepreneurs and
then anything else stress on your mind
I'd love to know you know anything that
you want to talk about but the Ghoulies
thing is a top-10 moment like like from
the heat I think everybody can associate
with this your friends random [ __ ]
becomes something you all talk about
from this was like
white-hot like I basically said the word
Ghoulies eighty-seven thousand times
over a one-week period and then one week
later the man who [ __ ] greenlit the
movie it was an amazing about it I don't
know if you I do remember the story you
know I am probably gonna like ruin the
whole thing i made i'm not trimming
easily I made Goonies or Ghoulies and I
never went to look to see which one was
ours after we had this no you would if
you made Goonies you would definitely
know it you know who zis is [ __ ] the
greatest movie of all time maybe they're
gone YZ or Ghoulies but anyhow we you
know we made the worst very cool YZ
which everybody is worse that's the one
America yeah we are not talking about
Goonies what I think is actually a top
10 movie now I would remember no no we
didn't make a Steven Spielberg you you
you made Ghoulies which is a movie that
nobody under do Pete what's going on
you got something yes
yeah it's it was anyway nonetheless does
look familiar
that's what everybody's watching who's
ton of entrepreneurs a lot of business
people why don't you give everybody like
a three-minute like kind of comic book
episode one who who you are your career
a little bit about you so on the career
side I always wanted to be in the
entertainment business from growing up
for no particular reason
where's you grow I grew up in Boston and
then New Jersey yeah and a part of their
Z South Orange loved it very close to
Wine Library my my wine store was in
Springfield Short Hills not very close
right those guys and I went I went to
Wesleyan undergrad I went right to grad
school out of college because I didn't
want to work and after a couple more
years in school yep and I was trying to
figure out how to get into entertainment
and a friend of a friend helped me get
my first job in entertainment which was
a summer internship at Viacom and I
worked there you know I had an amazing
summer met some people that led to my
first full-time job was which was at
Columbia Pictures Television in sales
which one really what I had in mind I
wanted to run a movie studio but okay
good place to start but flat out that
young age you like that's what I mean I
knew I wanted to run a movie studio when
I was 5 years old and I really and I
didn't how did you even know that exists
how do I even I didn't watch like I
wasn't allowed to go to the movies
particularly of it was a comparin
stalking about know is completely made
up my dad
was a lawyer so um no no clue but I was
committed to it so uh so it real quick
just for one more time cuz I need to
rewind that you're not sure cuz you're
young how it got into your zeitgeist but
you immediately became committed to it
yeah I think I had some sense like that
it was very glamorous yes and that you
could be looking at five you cared about
the girls already mmm I think it was
more about the money aspect yeah I
guessed wrong keep going yeah
little did I know yes there better ways
to make money um anyhow I got recruited
from Columbia to go to what what was
then the largest home entertainment
company a vest Ron it's the early days
of home entertainment that's how long
ago was and they were launching a motion
picture initiative and I became the
president of the company like nine
months later so I how old were you
that's 29 right basically three years
out of school yep and I mean I didn't to
say that I'd know anything is a gross
understatement I used to say my friends
are like this is a public company and it
was the biggest independent and there
the question was like why would you be
president this company my my answer was
well definitely not competent for the
job definitely glad they gave it to me
so I I did that and you know at this
point you know a lot of people were
listening like these days 29 having a
big company or a big job not insane
wasn't that either you know enter Tim no
no no they it's always been in business
that gave young people opportunity know
was definitely I mean you know is
precocious but I'm first of all an old
person talking about what it was like to
be young and successful as pathetic so
I'm not gonna talk too much about that
but no yeah you know Barry Diller was in
his early 30s when he was when he was uh
when he was chairman of Paramount so
he's not not at all unheard of
understood for successful people I bet
that went really well because the first
picture I greenlit became the highest
grossing independent film of all time
which I do remember which was dirty
dancing and then you know we and and
that's that that we made we made a bunch
of other movies there were some that did
very nice I mean this is how the
conversation went down with no no no we
made Ghoulies I'm I'm I know you're
committed to it but I think it's just I
just don't want people like look at I
know people are gonna be if it's not a
vest Ron
movie it's not a bestfriend movie like I
completely made it up and now Gary's
like it ruined the rest of his night so
it either was or was not distributed by
vest Ron and I'm gonna I just don't want
to get the ugly email saying I made that
movie how could you take credit for it
so but was it distributed by vest Ron
yeah you had a face or who's like
where's catalog isn't in now and then I
could tell you anyway moving on that
went pretty well I was recruited from
there to become president of 20th
Century Fox good and I was president Fox
I was a great run we had a whole bunch
of hits so after being in the movie
business for seven years I really sort
of revised my goals having met yeah I
thought was a very long-term goal pretty
quickly and I decided to revise my goals
say I really want to do something that's
in entertainment but also highly
entrepreneurial and I sort of surveyed
the landscape and I said and this is
1993 I said you know I think video games
are going to become a huge entertainment
business and I went to a company called
Crystal Dynamics which was a pre-revenue
video game company is the first CEO
built that company up and and then after
we sort of got it to critical mass I
left to do a turnaround of a huge record
company back in the days when that
wasn't an oxymoron no it was called BMG
yep and I went super well took it from
last place to nearly first place and it
would have been first place but one and
two merged so we were second place but
you know it was a great result we had a
lot of great hits and turned around the
Orsay label and other things and then I
revised my goals once again and said
okay my goal now is to run a diversified
media company that's supercharged by
digital technology and that was well you
was that that was a 1 and that was
considered somewhat out there I mean
people got the memo on digital
technology but I was always seen as the
new media person and I kind this was
post April 2000 where things melted yes
that's right and I and and you saw that
as the opportunity I saw it as an
opportunity I mean most people thought
it was a terrible time my view is
there's never a good time you know
there's no time when you're starting a
business and you look around say wow
this isn't awesome time it's always hard
that's right but it was it was the time
when I was ready and I I'd I was done
working for other people and so we
started what has become zmc
we had just you know it's always fun to
tell these stories so we had no offices
no capital no people not really a
business plan and I started the business
with three hundred thousand dollars of
my own money so for the last 18 years
we've been building up that company and
today we have assets in the many
billions of dollars and very little debt
great deal of cash and we own a number
of leading companies and the media
communications like and entertainment
business well our biggest company is
take two interactive which is a leading
video game company the third largest
with titles like Grand Theft Auto and
Red Dead Redemption and the a2k
Borderlands BioShock civilization many
others we own with partners nine story
which is a leading Canadian based
animation company great great hits and
great titles we have an investment in a
company called dynasty sports we own IT
renew which is a so-called itag company
it's a pretty arcane part of the data
center space we're big believers in the
growth of data we own canelo which is a
leading direct response television
advertising company add thrive a digital
advertising company and a number of
other interests and what's happening
with your day to day these days within
that ecosystem my day to days I'm a
partner DMC and I'm the chief executive
of take 2 so but but take 2 is a part of
zmc
so we have I have the luxury that I I'm
able to both invest and operate in the
media business and I am able to you know
our entire thesis is around is based
around the notion that technology will
continue to transform and inform median
entertainment and we only best behind
the thesis and the reason that we've
never suffered a loss and we've been
able to grow a very significant business
from nothing at least so far is because
we don't look at you know we don't look
at what's happening tomorrow or next
quarter or marathon year we look 5 10 15
20 years down the road and so far we
haven't gotten it wrong so no one people
in our business and we did have access
to capital or we couldn't have bought
these currencies people in our business
were buying
newspapers consumer magazines and that
was sexy and appealing we didn't do
those deals because we thought print was
compromised [ __ ] were right we did
however by an online market research
company before that was sexy and
obviously took over a video game company
you know seven that was very nearly
bankrupt and the perception was that
company you know was wet no chance of
making it that company's market cap
today is about ten billion dollars a
little bit more what's uh what's your
what's what's kind of most exciting you
right now as you look out five ten
fifteen years I think this is just the
beginning so for a lot of people a lot
of people think that I just heard this
at a got a conference you know we've
kind of established what the Internet
can do we've kind of established with
digital technology can do it's all gonna
settle down and now you know the move
forward in digitally driven media will
be evolutionary not revolutionary I
completely disagree I think the next
thirty or forty years will be the most
exciting time that the media business
Everett has ever seen and you will see
it in every part whether it's b2b which
were in or b2c which were in or pure
entertainment which were in or
infrastructure which were in and the
reason I believe in that is several
first well first is right because I
think was obviously right yeah that's
the answer yeah in the 1880s you know
there's a head of the US Patent Office
said I think pretty much everything has
been invented so you know I yeah we just
keep inventor either doesn't allow them
to historically understand the context
or they are financially invested in the
outcome that comes out of their mouth
and often not frankly emotionally
invested a hundred and staying head of
change it's more emotionally invested
change scares I don't you appreciate
this right like to me I'm of course
financially invest in all the things I
do however because I'm an entrepreneur
I'm putting my money where my mouth is
versus hoping that the exit that the
thing maintains for the next twenty
seven months because I need to sell my
stock at twenty seven months and go do
what I want to do personally after that
yeah was horrible way to live by the way
I whenever people give me a story like
that I'm like see here's the problem
with that plan you could walk outside
and get hit by a truck tomorrow you had
to be careful about delaying
for that so anyway I think you know if
you believe in Moore's law which I do
you believe that whatever data
consumption you want to project from
five years from now aggregate data
consumption you're wrong it will be more
couldn't agree more
you want to project what devices will
look like so Nick's holding an iPhone I
don't know which one looks like a nine
mine its new or ten so that that form
factor in ten years we'll look back in
that form factor and we will think it's
really funny I'm looking at a couple
cameras in here these form factors will
look really funny in 10 years they just
don't hurt some people don't it's
history right so you know rad as [ __ ]
the Walkman was I know you do yeah of
course
I think it was just like the plays you
couldn't believe it the razor phone was
the single most important status item
Seth you're old enough I'm impressed
like yeah people are unbelievably
confused about how it actually works so
what we do you know as we look at the
world and we try to think about where
that's going to be in five or ten years
and then you know to the point about
preservation versus you know innovation
or disintermediation we are to be the
ones to disintermediate ourselves and
that's a very hard task but if you're
worried about cannibalization in your
core business you should be the one
cannibalizing your core business or
someone else will do it for you
the something i said to a buddy a long
time ago that i use a lot i'm just first
time I said and I'll never forget I said
look I'd rather put myself out of
business and have somebody else do it
for me exactly exactly
it's exactly right now and when we when
I got to the record business in 94 the
first thing we did was launch websites
which was innovative right and start
thinking about how we can do digital
distribution by the way we didn't do
such a great job but we were trying
really hard we were surprised when the
Napster's came along we were prepared
for it and we were best positioned than
any about blockchain blockchain look I I
think the notion of a widely distributed
network you know for computing is fine
the problem with the blockchain
technology is so far anyway in for for
you to create the additional nodes you
have to create an incentive for people
to create the nodes right and so far the
incentive has been currency that's right
and so if you have something on one hand
has no owner as highly distributed on
the other hand has no built-in incentive
a bit of a question the Internet
built-in incentive which is I want to
express myself yeah or I want to
transact or I want to have you come see
something it was human um but it's hard
to know in the absence of currency how
you're gonna make the blockchain work
and then when companies talk about it
I'm convinced
you know when big big big companies sir
I mean people talk to us in the game
space about all the time when apply
blockchain technology the video game
business I'm like please tell me how
that works be and variant you just know
that they're putting hyperbole around a
statement and so right now like do I
believe in cryptocurrency I don't I know
they're plenty of people who do my
attitude is um I believe in speculations
they exist all the time of course but
anytime a so-called currency goes from
ten dollars to twenty thousand dollars
to thirty six hundred dollars in the
space of like my recent memory that's
not a currency that's something else
it's not a currency so and and for
people who transact outside the
legitimate economy they don't really
care because their margins are so huge
that what they care about is private
transactions but for the rest of us who
have like I have a really high margin
and most of my businesses but I don't
have a sufficient margin to offset that
kind of currency so I understand so I'm
not a believer at all in cryptocurrency
I think about sports betting I'm a huge
believer in sport well how do you I mean
first of all it's a little late in the
day since the US government already said
we believe in it we're taking it from
the governor or government saying it's
okay yes
to the state's regulating in a way that
works be complicated and you've got a
very powerful I grew up in the liquor
business between cannabis and sports
betting two things in the macro I deeply
believe it right but micro is different
and so you've got massive lobbies very
powerful lobbies who proven by the way
that they can effect a legislation of
late who have not just of late right but
in the casino business where so what do
I believe that if you're already in the
casino business in the US will you be
able to engage in broadly distributed
digitally driven sports betting yes do I
believe that we as a non regulated non
gaming company can take our sports
titles and turn them into gaming
opportunities it would be wonderful to
believe that and I'd be you know if I
were in the business of promoting our
security publicly I would say yes I
think the answer is the option
they exist but there are a lot of
regulatory hurdles yep there they're
obviously far fewer over them
internationally talk to me about I'm
gonna ask you a question that I'm
curious about so I've been really
enjoying similar to blockchain and
cannabis and sports betting the notion
of eSports teams watching a lot of
people deploy the logic around something
as you know this is where I get
interested I think this is from afar and
then you know it's very clear to me
listening to you there's a lot of things
that we cross over and agreeing on I'm
fascinated by people's inability to
synthesize things in lieu of what they
hope or emotionally or financially want
to happen
watching people deploy eSports
strategies in today's environments
fascinating because much like what you
did to whoever says to you we're gonna
do this blockchain thing I always say
the same thing I'm like please explain
to me why you think League of Legends is
like the major league baseball system
right and when you get into even a basic
first question and you want you watch
people dance in front of you what you
know now that I've got a better
framework of how you process and it's
probably why I like you you know what's
your take on on the eSports ecosystem
around the IP holders versus how the
teams think they're gonna conglomerate's
the pattern we're in the business right
so we and we eat our own cooking yes but
our view is that like major sports we
believe in eSports er yes 150 million
people who watch eSports there are a
whole bunch of people you're preaching
so for sure it's real it is however the
League of Legends business and it's a
billion-dollar business and in our world
video game business alone never mind the
media business never mind the sports
business video game business 130 billion
dollars a year currently he sports a
billion dollars it's a teeny little
business and the bulk of the market is
League of Legends and I say that as
someone who's a competitor we have the
NBA 2k league
yep so I think there'll be somewhere
between three and seven powerful eSports
that will develop in the same way that
they're between three and seven
professional sports leagues a truly
matter you know you got you got football
a baseball you got soccer especially
some of these iPS will come out really
lock in and absolutely will create will
become and they'll become very valuable
yeah and do you think teams will be able
to sit on top I'll play in all of them
so dividuals like I don't see a world
and this is
perhaps wrong yeah this speculative
where you the good news is for all the
things we've been right about we've been
wrong many times right yep and what I
say to people actually and ask my advice
especially when the entrepreneurs isn't
this is one person's advice but if you
ask the great entrepreneurs if when they
talk to people about their ideas people
all said high five that's awesome
that didn't happen so you shouldn't
listen to my ideas if you truly believe
you should go do it but in the case of
eSports I have to eat my own cooking I'm
betting on I'm paying for it yes so what
we said is look people love playing NBA
2k it's the biggest sports title in the
US has been for years people love
competing an NBA 2k they're doing it
anyhow so wouldn't it be sensible to
have teams that compete at any NBA 2k
and then a broadcast if you will learn
twitch yep those games that seems stand
to reason and so that's why we're going
for it do I think those teams should be
both NBA 2k and the other legends and an
overwatch next there's no real analogy
for that in professional sports I'm a
little skeptical I think if you want to
be the best NBA 2k player John Sanders
might just pop out of the side here yeah
you know it's possible and it's a
different skill set no question I think
if you want to be the best NBA 2k player
you're probably not also going to be the
best overwatch player do you what I
think is most interesting about your
saying to me is will they bake will
three to seven titles bake or because of
the notion of the framework different
different than creating a ball centric
sport which is what we're coming from
we're literally to me look ea just has
you know has a hit and it's like will it
be more like the movie and television
business where in perpetuity there will
be games that capture three four or five
years or are you saying Marvel Star Wars
you know there's I'm never saying that I
know that's what is sport but Marvel and
Star Wars there still will be a Forrest
Gump there still will be right and so
it's gonna be
they'll be interesting is if I'm
actually just literally as you're
talking like ooh so maybe it bakes three
to seven and or maybe baked six and
you're always an environment where
another four are always getting
five-year runs and seven year runs
versus the kind of five they get a forty
year run I'm skeptical only because team
play
watching team play seems to cluster
around these very ancient forms but you
know what this could be an example where
you know history just isn't a guide of
the future because after all League of
Legends does not look like hockey
football baseball or you know soccer
that's right so it remains to be seen
I feel very obviously very good about
our bat because I feeling down yeah yeah
you're right in the pocket but that's it
it's really about once watching an
Instagram Facebook put in your phone
numbers Calvin's ready to call we have
to give you an opportunity get some
access to this wonderful thinking you
ready for that one good yeah you can ask
personal questions too not just business
question I like business question do you
is there anything you want to talk about
that's person I know anything you bring
up I you know I like I like I like
trends I like macro thinking I love
history you know I like the way you're
kind of storytelling because it's
contextual which is I bet on context in
human behavior it's not super
complicated and I'm patient we are
unable to complete your soul at the time
now you [ __ ] up probably I'm gonna go
to next column well actually speaking of
that and that's vegan Mel no not Mel and
hold this for a second speaking of some
of our similarities how much do you get
excited about analyzing things that are
popping in culture is that something you
give a [ __ ] about things that are poppy
yeah like cool so that makes sense to me
based on how we're talking all the time
give me something is there anything
that's on your radar right now that
you're like huh or hmm
you know like or what's the last thing
with nine year olds or kpop like what's
in the hmm I would say hmm has been the
most recent social media apps that kids
are using tick tock yes that I had no I
was not familiar with and you know
that's musically reincarnation yes
exactly so what I have I have a young
guy yeah who every month comes in and
shows me what's happening popular
culture that I wouldn't run into smart I
know this is actually something I think
I knew her interns he's great
on that note you've done it he had a
delete any inappropriate stuff before he
showed me respect he thinks you would
give a [ __ ] how I long he's compared as
always great exactly you do a good job
of that right like are you
you have you know it's funny you just
said I don't know what that triggered me
but it seems like all of a sudden my
brain just jiggered and I feel like I've
come across over the last ten years
three individuals that talk about
spending time with you or having lunch
with your breakfast with you you're
doing that game huh I spend about 25
percent of my time coaching and
mentoring people at all stages of their
career all stages including people are
older than I but it does ten skew
younger and and I didn't do it for any
other reason except that you know I make
light entertainment for a living and I
really thought it was important to find
some way to make a difference and it
seemed that I could do that
he came and I saw I had an open door and
when you have an open door in a business
it's hard to break into like
entertainment you know what people come
home and so anyone you were I did it oh
you got to tell you I didn't do it for
this reason but I've developed an
extraordinary collection of friendships
from doing it of course so it's it's
actually been amazingly worthwhile and
after all that's how you and I met Dan
brought you to my house super set yeah
who's this
so tic TOCs on your radar yeah yeah yeah
and something next month what's
interesting about that in the macro is
it's it's people using something to help
them create hello hello I agree
who's this Andrew Andrew yes you're
Andrew right yes I'm Gary so else is
here - hey Gary say hey thrice how you
doing I'm good how are you good just
about to take my daughter home but how
to put my number up there how to tell
you Gary you've been an inspiration to
me thank you very much
thank you brother really appreciate it
is there anything we can answer anything
on your mind anything we can answer for
you so I just created it well let me
start off been an entrepreneur almost so
that was like nineteen okay I'm gonna
say okay my father's been a hustler you
know he sold pot he sold water filters
everything he's always been telling me
you know all we you know hustle hustle
hustle where'd you grow up so yeah that
was whoa what a New York love it keep
going new year new year
so one day I sat down with my sister we
actually opened up a liquor store yeah
we got about that go ahead yeah so how's
it going no III do it sweet thanks Emory
you and your sister just sit down and
the in the sofa in the living room like
let's open a liquor store and boom you
open a liquor store we've always kind of
thought about it and actually a place
I'll play opened up now when I business
I just took it over
no we just start from scratch we don't
know a bit about I love it liquor stores
so how's it going sorry um oh not so
good
why not so good what what's your hot
take what's your early how long have you
had it five years what are you what's
your read so not your hot take you're
like educated guess five years in what's
the struggle in your opinion to beyond
to just a lot of things just you know
lots of customers just maybe include
maybe does not bind enough liquor you
know it's for cost and everything art is
your yeah you know one of the tough
things about the liquor business in the
Northeast specifically in New York and
New Jersey is it's much more of a price
market than people realize it's hard to
differentiate when people know what they
want especially if you sell liquor and
beer one of the reasons I took my dad's
store from shoppers discount liquors to
Wine Library was very quickly as a 15
year old I said oh [ __ ] I am not
convincing this 80 year old woman that
just walked in that's been drinking
Johnnie Walker Black for 52 years to try
some other Scotch that I could make more
money on and the same thing became real
for me of like truck driver Johnny he's
[ __ ] drinking natty light like it's
hard for me to move him on the wine side
there was this exploratory kind of I
don't know anything about line I drink
Kendall Jackson and Santa Margarita and
silver oak but I don't I'm berry
insecure maybe you know something else
what's this Wine Spectator and Robert
Parker and I found my creative
opportunity and then once I understood
why
acres mattered I started painting
pictures and what picture getting
allowed me to do was split up the
business I sold everything everybody
knew about at cost
I literally sold Budweiser Shaffer
you know doors white label scotch Santa
Margherita everything that people drank
that they knew that everybody knew every
brand
I sold a dead cost and I spent every
single cent of my energy life that you
would walk in because you knew we sold
Budweiser at cost or more importantly
specifically to wine you knew that we
sold Kendall Jackson and Santa Margarita
dead costs there were the two most
important items and I would intercept
you through my merchandising or actually
being on the floor at first because we
were small company and I would try to
story tell to you why Santa Margherita
Pinot Grigio at $12.99 was overpriced
which it was which having truth on your
side was great and while you needed to
try this 999 Pinot Grigio but oh by the
way I was making $4 a bottle on that
versus zero on the $12.99 and then when
you tasted it and you and you liked it
better at least in the same ballpark I
started building trust you're in a
commodity business you have to create a
differentiator
yeah well instead of standing behind the
register wing for people to buy [ __ ]
honestly yeah I'm not gonna sell it
we're about to sell it actually okay I'm
moving on to I'm not going to move on to
nice projects you know I'm a local I you
know do a little bit everything I sell
jewelry I'm a DJ I'm a local DJ look
span and I'm one but one of the reasons
the liquor store might be [ __ ]
failing is because you're doing 87
things which means you're doing no
things yeah you gotta focus yeah it's
basically your Allegro that's a good
point like to me listen um um um I I
love chaos I'm doing 800 things and you
start doing it that's right and any time
I know I'm about to do so I did
vaynermedia head down for five years to
build a foundation I don't we call
people this we got a lot of lines of
business now you had a bunch of
companies want people calling brother
good luck
hit me on a deal hey can I stress go
ahead can I can I mention there's one
thing that uh I want to tell you I
called about I just started this new
application I'd I just made it up on the
iOS store is
for local DJ's and local photographers I
feel like this is gonna be the greatest
thing it's gonna build a two-way
marketplace to help people be discovered
right yeah yeah the hardest business in
the world that everybody wants to build
that's why eBay and we were on
trillion-dollar companies you know but
go ahead yes my so my question was how
do I gain the trust for my users to
start signing up
you mean the supply you know the actual
DJ's the actual those people were the
consumers to find yeah yeah no just
actual DJ's because it's when they start
signing when it started
my intuition my intuition on a limited
context I have 6 minutes and 13 seconds
into you I would go hand-to-hand combat
go hand-to-hand combat localized DM meet
people shake hands kiss babies get those
first 50 to 70 people people forget that
uber was in San Francisco for well over
a year almost two full years before they
even came to New York right everybody
wants to expand just win where do you
live right now New York no good young
win [ __ ] Yonkers one step at a time
I'm already impressed that you got into
the App Store a lot of people talk they
dream I appreciate the execution not
sure how you did it yeah there's an app
win [ __ ] Yonkers win Westchester let's
just start there and how do you do that
okay [ __ ] go to Google and go and go
to Instagram and use hashtags and find
the 50 to 500 local players in your
market and go buy them some french fries
give them a free bottle of booze figure
it the [ __ ] out handy I want to say the
name come on good we'll give it to you
and evently evently yes good name to me
yes do you know why I love the hustle
brother good luck good luck I think
especially was saying no I said a lot of
entrepreneurs will come and say you know
I want to have I don't want to just do
this thing I would do this thing and
then my that division I want that plan
and don't they'll outline three or four
goals at once and you know what I say is
I've never seen an entrepreneur not once
who started with more than one thing
I've seen plenty who haven't started one
thing and made it successful moved on so
I would say you know as entrepreneurs go
Bill Gates pretty good entrepreneur he
started with desktop operating systems
and they
with that for a long time long time on
time yeah actually this is a good segue
because this is something passion about
it might be a good place to take kind of
our back half of this meat of this
interview entrepreneurship it's become a
very different thing than what you and I
knew it to be for a very long time right
I was a bad student which was unusual
for immigrants from the former Soviet
Union all the kids you know I I took a
lot of ELLs along the way because I just
couldn't be anything else I just didn't
have it in me
baseball cards or anything else then
wine bubble uh you know I literally sat
sophomore year in high school and would
read The Wine Spectator cover to cover
and that's why I got these in F's in
science and so it was just it wasn't
viable you know I was this poor student
and and I was doing all the I was making
for $3,000 a week and selling baseball
cards but every parent of my friends and
every teacher told me I was gonna be a
loser there wasn't even the framework in
1992 89 to see the world through an
entrepreneurs eyes we are very much not
there now
that's right we are now in the other
place where career students have decided
they're gonna be the next Zuckerberg
right what you know I'd love to get your
perspective on the state of the union of
entrepreneurship through your eyes based
on the way I framed it up are you well I
mean things happening it's easier to
approach the world I mean we just talked
to someone who owns a liquor store who
just got an app in the App Store and you
know as you point out maybe if he goes
and hustles and promotes
it could take off yeah pretty crowded
place I was making I was just kind of
having a little fun with you but trying
to educate two-way marketplaces I mean
that is 9,000 times a day am i DM and
email I'm gonna because they what I like
is people scratch their own itch they
see the pain they just don't realize how
difficult it is to build a monster
that's base but nonetheless so I think
you know it's always been hard to build
a business that's highly successful it's
still hard today
I do think the world's a little more
forgiving today of people who take
non-traditional paths the cost of entry
ah no it's just got a little more
popular because you know really really
really smart people like Mark Zuckerberg
don't complete college and going to be
hugely successful but in fairness Bill
Gates didn't finish Harvard there he's
my age so I I think the front cost to
get in the game though have changed yeah
the upfront cost is way lower scale
the end code to get to the end consumer
the opportunity for great success is
still the same and and what about Mike
you know I apologize
micro success something I'm getting
outrageously passion about and really
the book that put me on a map you know a
lot of people like hustle and they take
shots at me I'm like did you read it
because really what I'm saying is my
intuition is 2008 is the way the
Internet's going specifically on social
is there's a lot of people can make 69
thousand a year being thrilled being an
expert in Smurfs or selling Jam who are
making 80 this was my thesis you could
make eighty eight thousand having a job
you don't love or 120 or you can make
seventy nine or maybe 140 being the
foremost experts of Star Trek and that's
what played out so that's for sure the
case our company at thrive allows
independent publishers to make a great
living some of them actually are
immensely successful sin has become huge
for some people it's a difference
between making twenty thousand dollars
in their spare time and making a hundred
thousand dollars a year which they can
live on and live on nicely especially in
stress this is something that has
happiness has to be talked about I I had
lunch with an entrepreneur today and
he's in the fitness space and he he had
walked away from a very big and
successful career as an actor to be to
go into the fitness space knowing full
well he would likely almost likely
person permanently make less money
because it pleases him and it's what he
loves to do and he's passionate about
and therefore he's great at it and he it
is his joy to spend his day in the gym
improving people's lives and and no he's
not living horribly because he's so good
at what he does you know my feeling is
you're really really good at what you do
generally speaking you'll make a living
the other thing is most people not
everyone most people are not once they
have food clothing shelter and the
ability to raise and educate their kids
most people don't care about incremental
money in term in terms of what truly
makes a difference in your happiness
some people do know some people do I
don't like people don't especially if
they can get into a place where they can
deal with outside judgment that's right
and don't aren't so insecure that they
need things to prove things to people
actually they don't when they're
self-motivated so one of the you know
when I coach people the question I start
with is what is it that you want that
you truly want not that other people
tell you
not they now you're trying to prove to
somebody exactly what is it you actually
won and think about with that life look
I asked you a question for me it's very
clear I love the game of itself the
process is so much more enjoyable than
the trophy like do you feel like you're
a process guy
well I'm very much I'm an achievement
guy I've decided I like doing hard
things yeah and that's why if you look
at what I do I do turn around say really
hard things India sometimes I think like
I'm intentionally the guy walking up the
hill with a backpack full of rocks and
if one happens to fall out I pick up
another one if I run into you I grab
your rocks too so I'm not sure it's
always the healthiest got it but I like
doing super hard things and then
pointing not to others to myself that I
was able to do that that means a lot to
me maybe too much to me though I care
about the money that comes with it yeah
I enjoy making money because it's fun to
make money it's certainly nice not to
have huge financial constraints and I
don't want to minimize that but it
doesn't does it motivate me day-to-day
no achieving interesting and hard things
motivates me and working in a field I
love motivates me I love media and
entertainment and I love working with
creative people which is how I spent
about half my day so in the last 10
minutes here that that really matters to
me what did we not cover or what from
your is there anything you'd like to
talk about I think I covered a lot of it
there are lots of things I like to talk
about but I think you sort of covered it
towards the end which is you know what
are we all doing here and it's tempting
to sort of focus on you know are you
gonna be successful or can you make it
or with a liquor-store be successful how
do you have hand-to-hand combat to make
your app successful you know I think the
thing I like to talk about is stepping
back from them which is why are you
doing this and you know if the answer to
the question is yes that worked out then
what's the question yeah you know if I
say to you you can you can have it it's
gonna work you know it'll be what you
want how many people have actually
thought about well what exactly is that
I would say the one thing that I'm super
proud of is it when I was really young I
knew basically what I wanted my life to
look like when I'm this age and while of
course I couldn't have predicted it
perfectly course it's pretty close
it was and the other thing is it's not
for everyone it's not for everyone but
it is for me
and I think one of the reasons
feel some satisfaction is not because I
feel like I crushed it not like I feel
like figured out and certainly not
because I'm the most successful person
on earth I don't feel any of those
things but I set out to have a certain
life that would work for me both
professionally and personally and more
or less that's what I got man I got to
tell you if when I tell people after
wishing people that I care about health
boy is self-awareness the next thing
that always populates because once you
map that stuff can get real interesting
yeah and and and and more peaceful 100%
I appreciate being on the show thanks
for having us see you guys you keep
asking questions we'll keep answering
them
hey guys thank you so much for watching
my video on YouTube I wanted to jump in
here at the end because I'm working on a
ridiculously important project for me
and I have a funny feeling you can help
if you drink wine at all or know anybody
that drinks wine at all please go to
empathy wines calm right now and sign up
for a subscription whether it's a three
pack whether it's a six pack or whether
it's a whole case of each for the year
if you drink thirty six bottles of wine
a year or give away thirty six bottles
of wine a year please sign up for club
empathy this project means the world to
me I could really use your support
[Music]